hi
everyone uh it is an absolute pleasure
and delight
and honor for me to invite you all to
this evening's wonderful lecture as part
of our distinguished speaker series
and our speaker today is
professor susan hockfield whom many of
you from the yale community
might remember and she will be talking
to us
uh about um her new book
uh titled the age of living machines how
biology will build the next
technology revolution before i turn over
to our dean of faculty
tamar gendler to give a more formal
introduction to susan
i just wanted to share a few things
first i wanted to give some bookkeeping
notices that
i request you all to mute your audio and
your
video because we are recording the
proceedings and
you will have an opportunity to interact
uh with susan and ask questions through
the chat
and we'll keep the chat open and we'll
read out your questions
susan at the end of her talk so i also
want
this point to thank richard and barbara
frankie who are joining us from
warm and balmy arizona for their
generosity
and support of the frankie program and
yale more generally which allows us to
do
lots of innovative cross-disciplinary
programming
and i think at this point uh the only
thing i want to say
is that i have a personal
fond collection recollection of susan
because by the time i joined yale as a
junior faculty she was the provost and
it was just wonderful to have someone um
warm and understanding and absolutely
brilliant
and supportive to be in the leadership
so tamar
i would like to turn it over to you now
to formally introduce susan
thank you so much thank you priya thank
you to the frankies who are here with us
today welcome president salaby
salve who is also present at today's
frankie lecture i'm tamar gender i'm
dean of the faculty of arts and sciences
here at yale
and it is hard to think of somebody who
epitomizes the values
of the frankie program more completely
than
susan hockfield the frankie program is
devoted
to bringing together multiple
perspectives
in particular the humanities and the
sciences
to think about the most profound
questions that the world brings to us
and susan hockfield has made a career
both intellectually and pragmatically in
her leadership as a scholar and in her
leadership
as an academic university citizen
of bringing together things that other
people
didn't notice the connections in
in some ways this is no surprise after
earning a ba in biology from the
university of rochester
and a phd from georgetown school of
medicine
susan hockfield joined yale in 1985
after a post at the cold spring harbor
laboratory
of james watson yes that
james watson the watson of crick and
watson
and this experience of having been
present
at moments of origination present at
moments of discovery
presence at moments where unexpected
insight led to genuine change
is characteristic of her time
as an academic and as a university
leader
she joined yale as i said in 1985 she
was tenured in 1991 the same year
i note that she was married in our very
own battelle
chapel and became a full professor
three years later in the department of
neurobiology
as a scholar she excelled but perhaps
even more striking was her capacity for
university leadership
she was appointed dean of yale's
graduate school in 1998 and stayed in
that role for four years
till 2002 when she took on the role
as yale provost and sadly for
us but happily for academia
served in that role for two short years
before she was
taken by our neighbor to the north
massachusetts institute of technology
where she served as a visionary and
transformative president
of mit from 2004
to 2012. as i've said already what is
characteristic and distinctive and
exciting
about susan hockfield's work is the way
in which it involves
bringing things together people
organizations ideas at
mit she had the idea that one
could use as a locus of
organization the convergence of
engineering
and the life sciences and through
that insight brought the world things
like the
david koch institute for integrative
cancer research
and the reagan institute of the
massachusetts institute of technology
harvard university and mass general
hospital
that is she broke down the boundaries
between the biological and the
engineering sciences
she broke down the boundaries between
institutions in cambridge she broke down
the boundaries
between the private sector and the
public sector for example
catalyzing the development of the
massachusetts green
high performance computing center in
holyoke which brought together
five universities two private companies
and the commonwealth of massachusetts
exemplary for our own ambitions in
planetary
science are the ways that she developed
at mit
a multi-disciplinary institute-wide
center
around energy which brought the mit
energy initiative to bring together
individuals from
almost every academic department at the
university to think about
technologies and policies for a
sustainable
energy future that practical
ability to bring things together is
combined with an
intellectual ability to bring things
together which all of us
are here to hear evidence of
and her new book the age of living
machines which serves as a beautiful
background
for her and should serve as a beautiful
background for your own bedside table
in the coming weeks is an extraordinary
exploration
of how biology will build the next
technology
revolution and with that introduction i
suspect you have no
longer any interest at all in hearing
from anyone
but the extraordinary susan hockfield
welcome home
we are thrilled to have you
thank you so much uh priya and tamar for
both the invitation
and both of your overly generous and
insightful
introductions um as um priya has just
mentioned i have a long history at yale
and immense fondness for this great
university and
and for its people um it is um
an indescribable privilege to join one
of yale's great conversations
here in the frankie program in science
and technology
um you know i offered very special
thanks and very special fondness to rich
and barbara frankie
great to see you um who have done so
much for yale
and who played such important roles when
uh rick levin recruited me to his
leadership team as dean of the yale
graduate school of arts and sciences um
and of course you all know that that
team came to include president peter
salovey and uh
rick's leadership team is well known for
producing leaders
not just for yale but for other
institutions and mit did take advantage
of it
and included recruiting me but um i have
to say i can never
thank rick sufficiently for changing the
direction of my career
i was on a path to understanding how the
brain assembles itself
over the course of human development uh
he recruited me into a new path
that he had confidence i would find as
interesting and as challenging
and that was to understand how people
can assemble
to accomplish more than anyone can
accomplish on their own
which has been a great challenge and
great joy for me
and for me the thesis of this lecture
series
is central to how i think and work as
tamar's described
and this is the cross-disciplinary
conversations
catalyze new insights they amplify ideas
and their impact
and they're just frankly a lot of fun to
participate in
um that thesis of
facilitating cross-disciplinary
conversations
is really the furniture of the mind if
you will
that was fostered during my 20 years at
yale
so with that uh short preamble i'm going
to start sharing my slide
so we can get started on today's topic
now i have to say i'm going to do this
with some little bit of technological
challenge but so um
following the theme of uh
cross-disciplinary conversations
uh today i'm going to share some
thoughts on our shared possible future
i'm going to talk about uh today part of
the story that
i've captured for general audiences this
is a book in my book
the book is not for scientists or
engineer it's for just plain old people
who want to understand
uh what the future holds for us what is
our very
probable uh technology future so
um i obviously have had the amazing
privilege
of leading one of the world's great
universities and as mit's
president mit is just a little bit of an
unusual place
but i had a breathtaking perspective of
the science and technology frontier
it's a frontier of ideas discoveries of
applications and
and much much more in the future i saw
was
frankly astonishing and today i'm going
to share with you a glimpse of that
very probable technology future
and i want to say at the outset that
while i'm optimistic about that future
those of you who know me know that i
tend to be crazily optimistic
i would say at this outset we have to
all agree
that the future looks a bit bleak so
today i'm going to share
both my optimism and also my caution
because i think both of them really do
need our attention so just to give you a
sense of some of the daunting challenges
that we face
the planet's current population of about
seven and a half billion people is
projected to grow
to about 10 billion people by 2050
and the demands of those 20 billion
people
will be unprecedented
uh and let me just call out just a few
of them if we think about health care
i mentioned here access accuracy and
cost
we spend in the united states about 18
of gdp
on our health care provisions
and while we do some amazing things
frankly we don't get good enough results
from that 18 of gdp we need to do better
in many dimensions
we need to be able to provide high
quality healthcare to
the poor and the rich alike energy
is a hugely challenging problem we
already
do not produce the energy we need and
use
sustainably and it's predicted that by
2050 there will be a doubling of
demand we simply have to figure out
how to provide the energy that the
world's population needs
without ruining the planet in terms of
water and food
we don't today produce enough of either
clean water or nutritious and healthy
food
that is enough for our current
population
and think of this that if we were simply
to use
today's agricultural technologies
to feed 10 billion people would require
additional farmland equal to the land
mass
of south america and africa
clearly that is not going to happen so
we need to develop
technologies that are going to produce
the food and the water
that 10 billion people will need now
of course if we don't meet the demands
of 10 billion people in these ways and
others
we can anticipate chaos and this problem
of a growing population's rapidly
increasing demand on the planet's
resources
is not new we have heard the story
before
many of you know of the reverend thomas
robert malthus
who in 1798 wrote a fascinating treatise
he calls it an essay on the principle of
population
he did a brilliant demographic study he
was a great democrat
he looked at britain and europe and he
made the observation
that at that time at the end of the 18th
century the rate of population
growth was faster
than the rate of increase in
agricultural productivity
and i can tell you you don't need to
know any higher math
to understand that this is a recipe for
catastrophe
malthus did a demographic study over you
know history and he showed that there
have been cycles of population rise
and fall and the periods of population
rise
always ended in tears war
famine pestilence and
this problem of rising population faster
than rising resources
has come to be known as a malthusian
dilemma
so malthus in 1798 was sounding a
warning cry
watch out the end is near we're about to
run enter
another one of these catastrophic
periods but
guess what at that time he
was wrong there was not catastrophe
over the horizon and he was wrong
because new technologies averted the
predicted disaster
what were the new technologies among
them were the
application of four-field crop rotation
by farmers in britain
thereby increasing the productivity of
their crops
and a marvelous new technology that was
one of the most important products of
those seafaring explorers who were you
know going across the seas around the
world
and while when i read about them when i
was in fourth grade
um they were in search of gold and
tobacco and spices and jewels and all
kinds of exciting things
but actually they came upon something
that was in even more important
in commerce and that was islands that
were inhabited only by
birds and were essentially huge
reservoirs
enormous piles of guano
bird poo well guano is an excellent
fertilizer
and they're developed a very robust
trade in fertilizer i will call it for
this
group to be nice about it around the
world that
really accelerated the rate of crop
productivity
and contrary to malthus production
uh people in britain didn't starve they
became well fed
and actually population grew and what i
often reflect on is it was just in time
for
the workforce that was needed for the
industrial revolution
now today we are facing once again a
malthusian dilemma and today i would
offer the possibility of using this same
kind of solution we need to invent
our way out but can we
can we defeat malthus again how do we
chart a course to a better future
now i didn't appreciate this of course
until i joined the rick levin team but
one of the central responsibilities of
every university president
is to imagine what will be needed to
solve the problems not of today
but of the distant future and i don't
know about all of you but
my crystal ball gets pretty fuzzy about
five years out
and i needed to come up a way to think
about what that future might possibly be
that didn't require this lousy crystal
ball that i had
so um the strategy to imagine the future
that i adopted
was it i thought that if i could
understand the future we're living in
today and how we got
here perhaps that would give me a path
to understanding what the future we
could might anticipate being living in
tomorrow
so let's just start by what is the
future we're living in today
does anyone have one of these in this
audience of course we all do
these amazing products
these digital products these cell phones
that every one of us carries around in
our purse or pocket
represent the major technology story of
the 20th century
it is the digital revolution i'm going
to divide my observations
today into three parts first i'm going
to talk about how did we get to the
digitally enabled world that we live in
today
i'm going to make the case the digital
technologies today are a product
of the convergence of physics with
engineering
which i'll call convergence 1.0 i'm
going to explain the history of the
digital world
and it's a history of discovery to
marketplace technologies
and then the second part i'm going to
offer a review of tomorrow's likely
future
tomorrow's transformational technologies
and where they're going to come from
and just as a preview we are on the cusp
of a new convergence
convergence 2.0 of biology with
engineering
it's already in progress and it's
rapidly accelerating
and to my mind it promises technologies
as impactful and as transformational
as the digital technologies we enjoy
today
and lastly the third part i'm going to
close with some thoughts on what we need
to do to accelerate those technologies
and the bottom line is as i said before
to defeat matthews again
we need to innovate so where did the
digital
revolution come from the digital
revolution is a product
of 19th century physics curiosity driven
fundamental discovery and fundamental
discovery
we know well in the university is
investigations without
any practical application in mind
so let me just go over a bit of history
that's likely familiar to many of you
on the left i'm showing a drawing from
michael of michael faraday
michael faraday was you know probably
one of the world's greatest
investigators of the behavior of physics
he studied electromagnetism and other
physical forces
and as i said he was studying the
behavior of these physical
properties not the nature of electricity
or electromagnetism
he didn't know what the forces were that
were giving rise to these
the properties he was studying and it
wasn't
until j.j thompson shown on the right
who discovered the electron in 1897 that
we began to have an idea of what those
forces were behind faraday's
observations
and it wasn't of course faraday alone or
thompson alone
there was a whole group of people who
were busy just
had to understand how these things
worked
with the elucidation of the electron the
proton the neutron
x-rays and other forces we
got into our hands a part list of the
physical world
electrons are a fantastically useful
part
and one of the important parts of a
physical
parts list physical world's parts list
of course
my dear friends the engineers like
nothing better than a parts list and
engineers picked up those
physical world parts and uh turned them
into practical applications the
electronics industry was born
and in that industry we've got vacuum co
2s and transistors which enabled any
number of new kinds of technologies
broadcast radio and television long
your long-distance telephony and a whole
universe of new technologies
and then the electronics industry has
had some
very useful progeny the computer and
information industries
this is the story of discovery leading
to industrial products
which have fueled economic and jobs
growth
it has been very productive not just in
terms of these digital technologies use
today but in terms of bettering the
lives of many
now the electronics industry was coming
along at a reasonable
pace but frankly a little sleeply
and invariably
technologies most powerful catalyst
is unfortunately war
uh napoleon recognized this when in 1805
he
repurposed laco polytechnique into a
military academy
he understood that to wage the wars he
was waging and about to wage
successfully he needed to have the best
technology on the planet
and so did we so during world war ii the
united states and
all the other nations invested massively
in technology
it's a fantastic story and of course i
can't dig into into enormous detail but
our nation's massive world war ii
investments in r d
led to technology miracles and
ultimately
won the war you know there's a whole
list of technologies that came out of
world war
ii would include radar many consider
radar to be
the war winning technology sonar
the atomic bomb certainly the war ending
technology
but in addition the foundations of
computing were laid the foundations of
gps and the internet
were all part of this incredible
technology and push for world war ii
the man who led this effort was vanilla
bush
who had been dean of engineering at mit
and then president of carnegie
so it was he who organized this
incredible effort now as the war was
drawing to a close president roosevelt
fdr
turned to bush and
asked bush to prepare a post-war plan
van ever bush did so end the plan
which was uh published in
a fantastic just an amazing treat it's
called science the endless frontier
put forward the thesis that briefly that
the lessons
learned in the wartime application of
science can be profitably applied in
peace
this was incredibly different
and uh startlingly uh counter-intuitive
after prosecuting a war successfully a
nation
is bankrupt they haven't brought
enormous debt
and the main biggest uh force after a
war is to reduce the debt and pull back
on expenditures
and bush was advocating exactly the
opposite
bush advocated that rather than pull
back
we should double down on those
investments
in science the endless frontier he lays
out all the different ways
these investments should be placed a
powerful blueprint
for america's second half of the 20th
century it was a blueprint for
economic industrial and sociological
expansion
he um advocated for federal investments
not just in research but in education
you all know about the gi bill which
provided
education for returning gis so many of
them would come off the farm
but to come back and get an education
college or
community colleges there was money for
mortgages and much more
he described a plan to accomplish these
efforts
essentially he laid out all of the
levers necessary to drive
technological and economic progress
and his plan would set the foundation of
the 20th century's most transformational
technologies and industries
including the computer and information
and aerospace biomedical industries
and everything that the united states
produced in the second half of the 20th
century
however his supporter fdr died
and fdr's successors were not as
enthusiastic as
building further debt and
um so they
were following bush's plan i would say a
little bit more slowly than bush
or fdr would have so the post-op
war effort got off to a slow start
until sputnik
1957 the russians
beat the united states into into space
with sputnik
and i recall this as though it were
yesterday that blinking light of sputnik
traveling across the sky cast a very
dark shadow
across this nation and in response
president kennedy announced a race to
the moon
and uh kennedy gave any number of
speeches about that quite inspirational
and this is a quotation from a speech he
gave at rice university
and i want to move this in a direction
beyond the technology he says
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things
not because they're easy but because
they're hard
and because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best
of our energies and skills
and this shared ambition
this national goal that kennedy
called out drove both national security
and economic and jobs growth
it was a far-reaching catalyst for
technology
for education and for industry
assured national ambition reaches well
beyond
those directly engaged in the effort
and i want to offer one example
now people often ask me
how i got into science and how i got
from
science to the presidency of mit
well the simple answer is that i grew up
under the shadow of sputnik
this is me with my three sisters
and um i was very fortunate we were all
very fortunate having parents who um
basically told us that we could do
anything that we wanted we just had to
have the ambition
and the willingness to work hard
so um for me then
and for my generation growing up under
the shadow of sputnik wasn't
the shadow of fear it was the bright
beacon of inspiration
but science could bring the world um
without any boundaries in terms of what
i could study whether it was science or
history or english
i heard president kennedy's call to
action
and i echoed it by articulating the call
for science in the new economy
and found my calling now this next slide
is a little embarrassing but i
just have to include it to demonstrate
what power a national ambition has even
on second year old second grade kids
so this is an essay that an illustrated
essay i
i it's a challenge to call it
illustrated because i wasn't a good
illustrator
um and it's a little embarrassing to
share with you i wasn't that good at
drawing
or you can see it spelling or add
grammar
or penmanship and i would uh you know
admit
readily that all those deficits uh
remain with me
however but even as a second grader i
got caught up
in the enthusiasm of this national
ambition that's
but that bright beacon through not just
me but a whole generation of children
fueled our national and soon-to-be
international ambition so whether you're
directly involved
or not you experience a sense of
reflected glory and a sense of you know
everyone
working toward an ambition that's
greater than your own
so um the other thing i want to call out
from this is the last
sentence i don't know how i knew this
when i was in second grade
that you could figure things out you
know maybe you'd figure out how to go to
the moon
but it would be fun so i recognized even
then
the magnificent and exciting paradox
that you can pursue your personal dream
and serve others and it is in many ways
a description of the power of shared
ambition
so the great war and then great shared
ambition and cold war fueled the most
powerful
transformation current of the 20th
century i'm illustrating here just a few
products of the convergence of physics
with engineering convergence
1.0 great policy important investment
for technology development the fueled
economic growth
and these technologies permeate every
nook and cranny of our lives
so the question is what's next how do we
defeat malthus this time
where will the future come from and as i
mentioned earlier
there's another convergence that builds
on this 20th century convergence of
physics with engineering
adding biology into it but biology
as late as 1950 needed several
revolutions of its own
in order to participate biology didn't
have a parts list so the first
revolution in biology that delivered the
parts list
was the revolution of molecular biology
molecular biology transformed the way we
thought about biology
it developed a biology parts list
starting with the description of the
structure of dna
and then the understanding that the code
the
vocabulary of dna the words of dna were
translated into an intermediary molecule
called
rna and that rna then was the molecule
that gave the directions
to construct proteins there are many
many proteins each very specific to a
particular cell or tissue or organism
but having these concepts in hand
gave biology the parts list it needed
of course we came to understand that dna
was the substance of heredity
and we could identify particular dna
segments that sometimes are responsible
for a disease
we can now construct molecules that
intervene
diseases by intervening at the level of
dna
or rna or protein it has been
an extraordinarily productive set of
discoveries
this parts list of the biological world
now um molecular biology gave us the
possibility to study
genes one by one incredible insights
but we needed another revolution to in a
sense
industrialize biology and that second
molecular biology biology revolution is
genomics
i'm showing here a graph that
illustrates the declining
cost of sequencing a human genome
that is perhaps the most important tool
that we have
in studying biology and applying biology
to other activities
i'm competing the cost of the genome in
the red line against
moore's law which is the incredibly
rapid
increase in the number of transistors
that can fit on a computer chip which is
a technological
marvel in and of itself but the
declining cost of a human genome
at least as i portrayed it here is even
more amazing
so the first human genome uh came out of
the human genome project
which was roughly between 1984 and 2003.
it took about 10 years to sequence the
first human genome and
depending on how you measure it it costs
between 100 and 150
million dollars to sequence a genome
this declining uh cost and increasing
speed and sequencing a human genome
today my colleagues across the street
from me at the broad institute
tell me that they can sequence a human
genome
not in ten years in six minutes
and the cost of that sequencing is well
less than a thousand dollars a genome
an extraordinary advance the point is
that having the understanding of the
components of molecular biology
and genomics we now have a biology parts
list
and when i arrived at mit i discovered
that my marvelous friends the engineers
were picking up this new parts list and
using it
to build new technologies in ways that
are
entirely transformative and quite
remarkable
so i'm going to uh the third revolution
that i'm going to talk about
is of course the is the convergence of
biology with engineering convergence 2.0
and there are a number of examples in
the book for today i'm just going to
talk about two i'm going to give you an
example from healthcare
an example from energy but the point of
my book and the point of today's lecture
is that these new technologies are
emerging all
around you and um if i can just give you
the
translation that allows you to
understand that this convergence 2.0 is
happening all around
you will see examples you'll see
examples when you pick up a newspaper
when you run into any
description of the science of today so
let's get started this is um a uh
the first example comes from my
colleague sankey de bocce and i'm going
to be a little briefer because i see
where
um i don't want to run over i want to
give you plenty of time for questions
so so akita bhatia is a nanotechnologist
she's an engineer she's also an md and
she's tackled
a problem of detection now you'll recall
that we talked about how much money we
spend
on disease if we use cancer as an
example of just the inefficiency of our
system
if you have cancer well actually let's
just back
up what's the best way of battling
cancer
the best way is not to get it and if you
use the tools that we have if you stop
smoking if you use sunscreen
i'm as guilty as anyone else and not
using sunscreen as often as i should
if you get the vaccines against the
viruses that we know to call cancer
all of that will reduce the amount of
cancer
in our population and indeed the
cessation of smoking or the reduction in
smoking has had a dramatic effect
on the incidence of lung cancer however
even if you did everything we know today
for preventing cancer
people still get cancer and the second
best approach for cancer
is early detection cancer is a disease
first of one cell then two
then four then eight these cells divide
and the earlier you
catch cancer the earlier you can detect
and remove
a cancerous set of cells the better
chance you have at a cure
however our current technologies while
they're much better than they
were before are still often insufficient
to detect a cancer
at a small enough size or a cancer
before it's moved from its tissue of
origin
to others before it's metastasized which
makes it a very difficult disease to
treat
so sangeeta has decided to tackle this
using the genius of biology on the right
side of the slide
and i didn't put my pointer up let me
see if i don't point her up
yeah hold on one second let's see
i hope you can see that on the right
side of the slide this
turquoise center this is a nano part
about 50 nanometers in size
that sinhita has decorated with a very
short segment of protein and that's
shown in this gold
with a little turquoise marker part of
that protein on the end
every cell every tissue
has its own proteins and its own
proteins that cut other proteins and
those are called enzymes
tissue specific or disease-specific
enzymes and that's illustrated by this
little pac-man this gold pac-man
character
which represents a cancer enzyme
now with this nanoparticle that sankita
has designed the idea
is that if someone is suspected of can
having cancer they get
injected with a nanoparticle and if they
don't
have cancer it remains intact and passes
out of the body
like other waste material however if
cancer
is present and these enzymes these
cancer enzymes
are present these cancer enzymes will
clip
these little protein tethers these
little peptide tethers
releasing the signal part of that
protein these little
turquoise loops
has engineered these loops to be very
small
small enough they can find their way
back into the bloodstream
and once they're back in the bloodstream
they are so small that the kidney
thinks their waste products and passes
them into the urine
so if you have cancer and you were to
get this test
you could you could gather your urine
and look for these turquoise
they're not turquoise and real
experiment but marker proteins
and because the urine normally has a
very very low background or protein or
any contaminant
you get a very profound signal to noise
uh sinkhead is starting to cut started a
company called glimpse
bio to bring this technology to the
market and they are
currently in clinical trials in their
animal models
this enzyme-mediated detection
technology
can detect tumors when they are one
tenth the size
of current best in class detection
methods
if we could detect cancer when they're
one temple
size we would have a very great
advantage
on beating it so these are the kinds of
technologies that come out of a
nanotechnologist lab but again
a nanotechnologist which builds these
little devices these nanoparticles using
nanotechnology but uses nature's genius
the
brilliant specificity and efficiency
of our enzymes to produce a deduction
technique
i'm just going to skip the next slide
and i'll just say very briefly that this
is
a an intravenous a bloodborne detection
assay
but sangeeta has also established this
kind of assay
as an inhaled assay to detect
lung diseases for example uh covid
and here the nanoparticles are inhaled
if you have the disease they get the
little marker proteins here they're in
orange get cleaved off and you exhale
them
with can which can be detected with a
breathalyzer the reason that this is for
me
such a compelling uh direction and such
a
compellingly important uh
set of possibilities that we we
desperately need
i gave the example for um for cancer
but frankly for me one of the most
painful parts
of watching kovid go through our
populations over the last year
was the lack of diagnostics we have a
diagnostics deficit in the country
that's bad for cancer and it's terrible
in the case of the pandemic
we need better diagnostics that are we
can detect
disease early as i've described
accurately
quickly you should be able to understand
whether you have covert or not within 15
minutes of walking into
your provider's office not after two
days
that are inexpensive that are sensitive
and that can
you know perform millions of tests we
don't have it yet
and i'm hoping that coming out of covid
we may actually get ourselves organized
around it
the next example i'm going to give is
from another colleague at the koch
institute angela belcher
angie is a materials engineer
and uh in this picture on the left
that's angie
and in her hand she's holding an abalone
shell
the abalone shell is filled with coin
cells batteries and they look like the
coin cell batteries that you might use
to change for your remote or any one of
your small electronic devices
however these just look like those coin
cell batteries because they're filled
with a new kind of battery that angie
has developed
and these are batteries that are made by
nature
when angie was a student at uc santa
barbara she used to walk along the
ocean's edge she loved the ocean's edge
but what she really loved were these
abalone
shells because she reasoned that abalone
a sea creature
picks up the materials from the sea it
lives in around it
and builds an abalone shell which is the
technology it needs it's strong
it's lightweight and best of all when
the abalone dies
an abalone shell disintegrates into its
component part so that the next abalone
can build its shell or
another sea creature can use those
components and angie thought
you know if abalone can build the
technology they need without
contaminating their world
why can't we so angie's work is devoted
to
using nature's tools
to build technologies that are better
and
as i described at the beginning we have
an enormous energy problem
and that's going to get much worse uh
and we have to figure out how to
address it now people are enthusiastic
about alternative energy i love wind i
love solar too
but the rate limiting technology for
getting out of our energy dilemma
frankly is not
bigger wind turbines or larger solar
farms
the problem the rate limiting technology
is energy storage
batteries we've made a lot of
improvement in battery technology
but frankly state-of-the-art lithium-ion
batteries are not
the end of the story for us they can't
be
in order to manufacture lithium-ion
batteries you need an
enormous amount of heat it's a very very
intensive heat process so it consumes a
lot of energy
and there are a lot of toxic byproducts
so unless we figure out how to build
batteries
more sustainably we are not going to get
very far
with the best alternative energy
strategies that we can imagine
so angie has done a number of things but
for the battery application
she has used a small uh bacteriophage a
virus that
infects bacteria and it showed here it's
called the m13 battery
uh virus it's um and she has
uh she said as she describes it she's
caused nature to evolve faster
viruses normally bind living organisms
material from living cells and angie's
question is could she persuade these m13
viruses to bind battery materials
in organic materials and indeed that's
what she's done
i'm just going to show you a slide just
to illustrate how these batteries
are built so here over on the left is an
m13 you see it's quite small
less than 10 nanometers across and it
has a very
uh repetitive structure so there are
proteins called p8 that forms the core
the tuft of these viruses formed by a
protein called p3
and she has modified the p3
proteins so that they bind single walled
carbon nanotubes which are very good
conductors of electricity or in some
cases cobalt magnesium lithium
the components for batteries once these
uh
viruses have been modified they're kind
of crystalline so they
uh pack together very closely the way
crystals do
and then she uses them to build cathodes
she also this case in this illustration
the anode is
lithium foil but she's also used
virus-built
anodes she packs them together into
these
coin cell battery cases and they look
just like any old
coin cell but they're not because
they're built from nature
most importantly her battery
manufacturing
technology builds these batteries at
room temperature without any toxic
byproducts
if we could build the batteries we need
using angie's technology
we would have a chance to get out of our
dilemma
with about of having insufficient energy
so two examples um that um i think are
just you know
fabulous uh illustrations of using
nature
to uh build better
so um now
these convergence things are easy to
describe but they
are hard to do why is it hard to
implement and accelerate convergence the
first is the innovator's dilemma if we
think about our universities just in
terms of
making it possible for people to talk
about across disciplines for university
who work pretty darn well
and if you're going to be a chemist it's
important that you learn chemistry
probably more importantly you learn
chemistry then you understand how
semiconductors work
however this is a problem in terms of
advancing into
our next world and the challenges across
disciplines
makes sense disciplines use different
languages
they use different approaches and of
course there are any number of
structures institutional structures that
make it difficult for people to
communicate across um across disciplines
and our funding agencies are siloed
um this to me has been a really very
very difficult problem
fabulous for van aver bush to have said
let's set up these funding agencies but
the fact is that the national institutes
of health has done a fabulous job
at funding biology and biomedicine the
nsf has done a fabulous job at
funding you know computer science and
engineering and the department of energy
has done a fabulous job at funding
physics
just the question is how do you provide
funding for
activities across disciplines once in a
while we've gotten this together there
was a national nanotechnology initiative
that brought together four different
agencies
and really propelled the united states
from being a laggard
to a leader in nanotechnology the
current brain
project also brings together many
different agencies to solve
the some of the really daunting problems
of decoding the brain
but the fact is those are exceptions
they're not the rule and we need to be
able to
do cross-disciplinary funding and work
without inventing a new process to do so
every time i'm going to give you just
one example and i'll go through this
relatively quickly of one of our
convergence efforts at mit
this is the koch institute for
integrative cancer research
we put it together in 2007 the building
was done in 2011
and i have to say there are several
things that um
make this work the first is that
everyone in the building shares the
ambition
to accelerate progress against cancer
and the second is that there
is protected space all of the faculty
in the koch institute have their faculty
appointments in their departments
in biology in mechanical engineering in
the department of materials sciences and
engineering
and they just cohabitate for their
research so we didn't have to change the
academic process of faculty appointments
that really allowed us to accelerate and
the third element that is absolutely
critical success is we had seed funding
outside of standard funding practices
what do i mean
private philanthropy enormous generosity
by a number of philanthropists that
allowed us to get started
and prove what we said we were going to
do
which then allowed us to get funding for
this from the standard agencies
but that was absolutely essential and um
we built this building and established
this institute
with the determination that we were
going to
foster collaboration and we engineer
with four layers of collaboration up
here in the top left shows an original
floor plan of one of the floors of the
building
um all the floors are mixed with
engineering and biology we want to
encourage people to
talk together and this was the early
plan and now as faculty have left
new faculty have come it's actually more
integrated that you don't have a biology
half an engineering half of a floor
importantly the building has one set of
stairs one set of elevators one set of
restrooms
one cafe so wherever you go you're
likely to run into someone
who comes from the other side of the
equation and that's been enormously
helpful
we situated the koch institute among a
number of other
disciplines uh obviously next to the
biology building this data center
is the home of electrical engineering
computer science right across the street
or the broad institute
the white head institute chemical
engineering is here
chemistry is right here makes it very
easy as you cross this courtyard
again to run into people who aren't
exactly like you and easy to start those
conversations that might otherwise be
difficult you all are certainly aware
that mit does not have a medical school
or a hospital
this is the third layer of collaboration
we have to establish collaboration with
our clinical
with a available awareness and
understanding of cancer
along with our biologists and engineers
and of course i would be i'm telling you
only part of the story if i didn't
remind you
that mit which are these buildings shown
in red are embedded
in the kendall square innovation
district my colleague
the nobel prize winner phil sharp often
says that
technology travels on two feet and it
does
and so it is just say uh we've lowered
the barriers for translating great
discoveries
into marketplace life-saving products by
where we sit
because if your office is here in the
koch institute you don't have to walk
too far
to talk to venture capitalists and
people in the
industry community so
um does it work this is just
one way you measure it obviously there
are more grants and
more publications but because we're
interested in
implementation we kept very close track
of the companies that have started out
of the coke institute you can see back
here when we started the koch institute
in 2007
a few companies were being started and
we now
have more than 100 companies that have
been founded out of work at the koch
institute
among those companies at least 30 of
them now have products in clinical
trials so
we feel that we're really delivering on
our ambition to accelerate progress
against cancer so um
what is convergence 2.0 good for i would
say
just about anything um and i've given
some examples here
and we talked about some of the
challenges of the 21st century and the
importance
of tackling them in a way that will
not just solve these problems but in the
best of
scenarios also drive the kind of
industrial and economic growth that we
enjoyed in the second half of the 20th
century
so the answer to the malthusian dilemma
of course is
more innovation but
we have to invest massively in
innovation for
it to work and that is always suspect
research is inefficient you never know
where it's going when you embark on it
and um since the early part
of the you know second half of the 20th
century where we got on to the
van over bush plan we have invested
significant federal funds they have to
be federal funds because the process of
innovation is just
too slow for a company to invest in this
kind of work
they will invest later on when an idea
is beginning to mature
but not at the outset and this is the
responsibility of the federal government
however
it is always doubted this is a story
that may be apocryphal
apparently the then equivalent secretary
of the treasury the chancellor of the
exchequer william gladstone
asked faraday why he was bothering to do
his kind of bumbling around in the
laboratory what was
it was going to what was the worth of it
and faraday is reported to have
have replied why sir there's every
probability
that you will soon be able to tax it and
indeed when i
bought my last iphone i did pay some tax
on that
um it is the route to economic and
industrial progress
but we have to fuel it from the very
beginning so
bob solo and mipt economist did the
great
uh study that showed that over 50
percent of economic growth since world
war ii
is due to technology not the standard
components of of
and of the economy a very important
study that demonstrated the real product
how much uh a nation can gain
by investing in the raw material of
innovation
so how are we doing um this is a diagram
showing in red
uh our investments since 1950 through
three in uh r d
i'm showing both the federal funds and
also business funds
uh in blue and i just want to remind you
that you know the business funding side
is
more on the development side of the
research and development the r
d side um but it's the research the best
fundamental research side that the
federal government has been responsible
for
this graph shows it as a kind of a
national commitment to this effort
and by demonstrating the percent of gdp
we got started in the 50s reached the
peak
in the mid 1960s and has been tailed off
this graph doesn't go all the way to the
present day but today it's about 0.7 or
0.8 percent
of gdp that goes into this kind of
investment in our future
and you know you can say well it's still
a lot of money and it is a lot of money
of course won't surprise you that i
think never enough money for this
particular effort
but you know and after world war ii we
were in this game by ourselves
the countries that could have competed
were putting all the money they had
into rebuilding their cities and their
countrysides that had been decimated
during the war
the united states was in a very
different place we
had the let's say the luxury of
investing
in our future in the world's future but
that's no longer the case
there's a lot of competition out there
and you can say that's a good thing and
it is
here are the numbers from number of
countries around the world
and you can see already that south korea
japan and germany
invest a greater percentage of their gdp
in research the line i worry about a lot
of course is this purple line china
and i don't know whether this purple
line has yet crossed the red line my
guess is it will
have already done so last month or if it
hasn't already done so it'll be next
month or next year
the way the united states
has managed our technology and
come to the position that we have
through the 20th century
is not a secret it's there for all the
world to see
and all the world is as rapidly as they
can
following our pattern so
if we want to be a player a major player
going forward we have to
continue to make these investments so
there are things about our federal
policy that i think
are essential to building this
incredibly important resource for
the country we need to have sustained
federal investments in basic research
i paid attention to this of course as
soon as i started my own lab where there
were rich years or you know particular
more generous years and
four years in terms of getting uh
federal grants to do our research and
nothing could be more debilitating to a
young investigator than not to be able
to get the funding to support her
or his research because of the vagaries
in funding
funding needs to be consistent very
important
for this convergence 2.0 and for
whatever convergence three play always
going to be is that we have flexible
funds
available for cross-agency
collaborations to fund the kind of work
that i've described today and that i
have in my book
importantly when an interesting idea
gets out of the lab and is ready to go
to the marketplace
we need policies that better support
investments in innovation
we do have a robust
investment mechanism in the united
states but
i would say we could do more to
encourage individuals and
investors to put their money into this
kind of
work and um it may sound weird coming
from mit
where we're known fairly well for our
ability to
transfer technology from the lab to the
marketplace but even in mit
i think we can do a better job of making
it easier making it faster
because these industry university
collaborations are critically important
to
um get across the
gap between a laboratory discovery
and a marketplace technology that's
going to save a life
so um i've described you uh
the products of the convergence or some
of the products
at least the thesis behind convergence
2.0 which i think
will be the technology story of the 21st
century
it's a story of you know fundamental
research that moves to applications that
move to new businesses and new
industries
and you know we simply
must defeat malthus
again but my very greatest hope
is that defeat of malthus i hope
will come not from the threat of war
but by the promise of peace
so my book gives you a front row seat on
some of the most amazing
almost science fiction technologies
coming out of labs right now
as i said it's written for a general
audience and i
just hope everyone can enjoy the
excitement of
this generation's technology revolution
and to understand it and i hope you will
thanks brielle take some questions now
thank you so much
uh uh susan for sharing your vision
and i am delighted that uh
our president president of yale peter
salve a former friend and colleague of
yours
uh would love to ask the first question
so peter
hey peter well that's happening uh it's
great to see you susan and
priya thank you for uh hosting us and
for calling on me to ask the first
question that's very nice of you
tomorrow that was a great introduction
and rich and barbara frankie thank you
so much for
enabling all of this and so much else
that you do
for yale um just before i ask the
question uh
uh it's great to see about a hundred
people with us today and
one thing i did want to uh uh
acknowledge
is that susan really is my mentor as an
administrator
and back in january 2003
it's really december 2002 rick levin
asked me to be
dean of the graduate school when susan
moved over to the provost office
and he gave me about a half a day to
think about it
and about a week
to get trained up and start and
susan uh was always someone who's
was kind of a role model and then who
tutored me during that
holiday break and got me um tuned up to
become a dean and
i i had no idea where that was going to
lead either and
at the time i just wanted to see if i
could get through january 2003 without
doing something foolish and but susan
was a great great teacher in this other
area of university life and i'm very
thankful for that
um we're we're trying here at yell to do
some of the things that uh you have
suggested uh
uh that we do in order to uh create
convergence
and and and produce change in the world
uh
we're also co-locating uh faculty across
disciplinary
boundaries so uh in the humanities you
could see people coming together in our
new quadrangle and
in the woodside institute at hunter
college street you can see
neuroscientists and psychologists and
computer scientists and
some data science all converging
klein what used to be called klein
biology tower is now the klein tower of
data science astronomy mathematics right
so
we're doing all this co-location and
certainly we're
we're trying to engage philanthropists
as you suggest and we're doing more
industrial collaborations with industry
uh
as you as you suggest and particularly
for yale that was a new
uh has been a bit more of a new
adventure and and has been a successful
one
so my question is should we go further
uh you know i i i'm not suggesting this
seriously so nobody who's
watching should panic but but as a
thought experiment
you know break down the disciplinary
barriers completely not have
not have departments anymore not you
know maybe not even have schools
admit people to phd programs in science
or
humanities or social science um
should we there's one university out on
the west coast
where faculty move between industry and
and and the university uh with almost no
barriers so one year they're at google
one year they're at stanford doesn't
seem to matter
and uh you know should we really go
further should we should we
uh i think co-location is great i think
raising money is important and uh
industrial collaboration has
uh i think created new avenues but uh
should we should we we as yell or we as
academia however you want to
uh answer it should we go should we go
even further
yeah it's a great question peter and
it's one obviously that i've been
i've gotten often and um it may surprise
probably not you but others that um i
actually
you know people would ask me well you
know don't we need to change departments
and i'm
doesn't i i wouldn't even know how to
begin to think about changing
departments
and people need an intellectual home and
people need to know
something right you know all of this is
possible because the people who are
participating are deeply rooted in a
discipline and they know
you know what that discipline brings
them and the question is how do you
provide the flexibility
so you can have the conversations with
people from a different discipline
to come up with a new idea so i you know
i would often say you know i don't know
what the you know
names of future departments would be but
we need more flexibility
and i'll tell you peter you've probably
seen this also
the students the next generation
are lunatics about this you know so they
are
even you know with the time i first
arrived at mit in 2004 and i would
you know when the freshmen arrived you
do the same thing wander around campus
and start up conversations with
our new members of our community and i
said what do you think you might want to
do
and a huge fraction said oh i want to do
you know biomedical engineering or i
want to you know just you know
they they got in and that has only
increased
one of the things that we've done at mit
that i think is
good for both the faculty and the
students is that when i arrived
the undergraduate majors were
disciplinary
and if you wanted to add something on
you could
but you know the student schedules are
already pretty packed and it
was doable but not easy and now we have
a whole
array of hybrid majors so you can
major in biology and computer science
you can major in neurobiology in
computer science
you can major in you know anyway there
are a number of these
hybrid majors and it's important because
for two reasons one is the students want
to do it
and but the other reason it's important
is it gives our faculty
a chance to pioneer these new fields
because
you know well that it really is
in architecting our majors
our requirements that we architect a
field
that's the way we pioneer fields and so
i think that
i wouldn't abandon all the organization
because people like
you're a psychologist you know better
than i um how much good comes out of
a more intimate community when that
community is situated
in a candy store of other opportunities
um so i'm not a fan of letting everyone
loose to you know self-associate
but i am a fan of what i often describe
is um
you know turning foot paths into super
highways you know you'll figure out
how to make the connection with a
physicist you want to talk to for your
experiments right
and once you've kind of bushed whack
your way between disciplines
why should the next person have to go
through that same bushwhacking process
and so
you know putting in place the um as i
said you know the superhighways rather
than just the footpaths
that i think is a way of creating this
and i'm
really a a huge believer of a lot of
confidence
in bringing our students into this
reinvention of the future by giving them
the opportunities to um
as a colleague might be the plasmids uh
so the plasmids are these genetic
elements that move
knowledge from one cell to another
and so the students really are in a
university uh the information
carriers that are the real people who
are doing the bridging of disciplines
thank you susan it's so good to see you
it's great to see you peter
um uh thank you so much susan and i
think from your talk we could see the
imprint that you have left on the mit
campus
as an alum i have seen the
transformation is incredible
i really hope you can come to yale to
our campus and to see how things are
changing
um in the geography and in terms of
these intellectual connections so we
have a lot of questions
and i'm really tempted to ask you one
myself before i launch
and that is you know you discuss this a
little bit uh in your book and i was
curious about your views
so you know there's been um there's been
a talk about
by economists like mariana matsukato and
others
who've talked about how maybe the
federal government and federal funding
for blue skies research
should have some incentivized way of
returning some money
back to the government so you can um you
know grow this
blue skies fund from the federal side
always so for example you know a simple
example that she often cites
is google that came out of the nsf's
libraries project if only they had said
point zero zero one percent if your idea
gets monetized comes back
for blue skies research so i was very
curious whether
uh what your views were on you know
other than
philanthropy and industrial partnerships
whether you felt that the federal
government
had a larger role to play in fostering
this new kind of innovation
yeah priya thanks for that question and
you've touched on something that i think
is really key
and most people don't appreciate which
is it
is a nation that wants to be part of the
industrial future
has to invest in
the infrastructure right in the ground
floor because the ground floor
you don't know where it's going you have
to invest you have to do it wisely
van over bush was so brilliant and
saying that we have to provide
federal funds for that because no one
can afford to invest in it
you never make enough money out of it
directly
but as you say there's a huge amount of
money that's produced and we
have to understand that
investing federal funds in the
you know the first steps of this
enterprise is absolutely required
you know the idea is you can buy it from
someone else that's you know
clearly a fool's errand that has not
worked for any nation although
um you worry about patenting and
copyrighting
uh people often remind me that um the
united states
didn't have copyright laws until we
started producing enough books and
britain was furious that
for example charles dickens books were
published in the united
outside of st so i you know so i think
it's important for us to invest in i
don't
know i mean obviously i've been involved
and you've been involved
in telling the story of the critical
role of
blue skies research but um i do
believe that um as you say
that the companies the industries that
have
profited from that research should be
returning
and frankly they do return some of those
profits back into the
into the federal government federal
government has to decide how to use
those funds and of course there are
infinite demands
um but i think it's absolutely essential
and i just wish i had um
kind of a magic formula to help people
understand how important it is but
i think that any nation that wants to
be a an industrial and economic force
has to invest as generously
as imaginable uh in this kind of effort
and it's why i showed these comparisons
between the united states and other
countries it's not a surprise that
germany and south korea and japan
industrial powerhouses are the countries
that are investing more than we are
as a fraction of gdp of course
great um tamar uh if you had a question
now would be a good time to go because
there's a real pile up
there's a whole queue i'm happy to pass
my spot on to a colleague
great so there's a the first question uh
was from justin zarembi who said uh it's
very striking when ben labs got rid of
its fundamental physics research in
about 2008 or so
what would it take for commercial
ventures to explore basic research
alongside
applied research or does the
inefficiency of basic research limited
to existing within university settings
solely
hey justin thanks for thanks for joining
us today
i was so happy to see your name in the
list of attendees
um so you know you've actually um you
know asked the critical question so why
was there bell labs why
was there a ge research and it was
possible because those companies
um i wouldn't go so far as to call
monopoly but they actually
controlled so much of the industry that
they had the resources and they were
funding you know frankly not simply
their own work but they had the
resources available to fund it and as
um uh i'll use a kind word as
uh industrial economics became more
efficient
uh those kinds of resources were not
available
for claim to be not available and so we
have very very few industrial research
labs of the sort that bell labs was bell
labs was
you know obviously you know legendary
for the kind of physics fundamental
physics research that they did
and you know you might say you know this
is something that
um we could dream of but the economic
structure doesn't support it
and um you know what would it require it
might require
a kind of you know federal accounting
but
how would you measure what research was
really blue sky research and what
research was really the
you know the d side of r d the
development research
and um you know i think um
uh it's my guess although i haven't been
inside um
the companies that are involved in space
exploration now
i don't know how much fundamental
research is going on there but my guess
is probably uh not so much
uh so i actually i'm a fan of the system
we have
but i uh desperately wish
that as a nation we were
as committed to our future as we are to
our present
great thanks uh the next question is
from james fairweather
uh and the question is do you think that
biology is quickly approaching the same
level of development practice
as software so sort of the idea of
version control
software defined vaccines patch upgrades
of software to improve performance etc
etc
if so how long you reckon before biology
develops the same standards of
interoperability that accelerated
mechanical engineering
sort of the standardization he's saying
of examples of thread sizes dimensioning
etc and in electronics with interfaces
and discrete components and software
with cloud software defined
infrastructure
you know it's a great question so it's
the industrialization of the biology
parts list and that's happening
um you know it's not uh so hard to um
you know get a bio
biological piece that you need i think
one of the um
um and i'm speaking about this as
someone who knows very little about the
world of computer science
one of the remarkable things about
biology
is we still are discovering new things
and so it's not as though
we have completed the biology parts list
it's not as though we understand
all of the pieces that make a biological
organism work
we are discovering new things every day
i mean i
hesitate to bring into the conversation
but you know crispr
uh cast nine you know who would have
thought that this kind of system existed
and not only have we discovered it but
we've also figured out how to deploy it
for any number of uses
and so um i don't know that um
in this kind of regularization
standardization obviously the
elements themselves
have a you know a structure and a
limitation
to them but i don't know whether we'll
have the kind of standardization
that now exists or is evolving
in the computer industry good question
um so the next question uh is from barry
abell and he asks all of this depends on
the brain as a resource yet the brain
sciences
have somewhat lagged behind particularly
psychiatry
can you speak to the importance of
focusing this convergence on ways to
help
brains function better yeah it's a great
question as a neuroscientist um
i feel quite humbled because um
neuroscience has
moved more slowly than we would have
dreamed and
it's another place where there's a lot
yet to be known
and um you know obviously you know i've
got a um
you know a single tool to increase that
knowledge and it's just
you know increasing the kind of research
we do
um and i think one of the
great disappointments of biology
as it's evolved up to today is that we
have yet to um have the kind of
interventions that
would um allow for us to tackle the
kinds of really
horrible diseases of the brain there's a
chapter in the book
about bionics and um
i have to say the progress in developing
smart prosthetics
is breathtaking and um the smartest
prosthetics
of today are worlds
different from the dumbest prosthetics
of yesterday
however um figuring out how to
um regrow connections in the brain has
been
quite daunting but i have confidence
that with
more of this kind of fundamental
research will get someplace but i have
to say i've just
broken the premise so the premise is for
blue sky research is you don't know what
you're going to come upon
and um we desperately know what we need
in terms of psychiatry and neurology
we're just having a hard time putting
the pieces together
and i would say as
[Music]
disappointing as that is it also
points to the fact that there's so much
more that we need to learn
and so um you know it's a it's a tough
message to hear and you know as
neuroscientists we hear that message
every day
but i think that um uh i can't even
begin to imagine where we're gonna be in
five or ten years but the progress has
been incredibly
uh rapid just in terms of how much we
understand about the fundamental
structure
the development of the brain
right so um while we sort out the next
set of questions
uh i have one burning question so i'm
going to sneak it in here
um so um susan a lot of what um
you've discussed right um we are talking
about
a highly advanced country these
technologies that might
provide um solutions
primarily aimed at the wealthy so
i i was curious about how you thought
we could move forward uh and defeat
malthus but
also envision a more equitable world
especially right now even with just the
covet 19 vaccine roll out and you know
this is a perfect situation where you
know the entire for the world to be safe
we all need to be vaccinated and it's
not going to be enough just for the
wealthy countries in the west to be
vaccinated
given how global we are so how do you
see
this convergence spreading and
radiating out um in a more equitable way
because our survival we all know is
really bound up with each other in such
an
intricate way yeah priya this is such an
important question
and um in the chapter on food and
agriculture
um i do touch on it and um one of the
things that
um is just um stunning
is the insufficiency not of advanced
therapeutics but frankly just food and
water in the developing world
and one of the problems with water
purification is it's just gosh darn
expensive
we're lousy at purifying water and i
offer an example of something that
promises a completely different approach
to water purification that could
be efficient and could be economical and
the same thing with food i mean
you know among for me one of the
tragedies of
you know recent decades is that
um you know there are viruses there are
plant viruses that wipe out crops that
you know that people rely on cassava
is a is a crop that um you know the most
needy people in the world rely on to
survive and
cassava has a virus that will wipe out
the entire cassava crop for
you know and leave people totally
destitute
and there is a a
way of genetically modifying cassava
there's a strain of cassava that has
been
modified to resist the virus and um
that crop was basically fought against
because of people who are anti-gmo and
you know my view as well
if you can help people why not help them
and so he gets caught up in a lot of
politics and i think that does slow us
down
but i think there are so many people
that are absolutely devoted to
moving these kinds of technologies and
discoveries into the media's population
um if you look at what's happening with
the vaccine distribution we're slow i
mean i would say vaccine distribution in
massachusetts has been
ridiculously poor um
um but there but there are enough people
i think
and enough momentum to actually get the
vaccine um
out to people all over the world who
desperately need it if you think about
what we've done with measles
and smallpox uh in terms of distributing
these
these um therapeutics and and uh
preventatives i i
i would like there to be more um but
um the awareness of it i think has
increased dramatically
thank you so much um so i think um we
are coming up to 5 30 so i just wanted
to end with uh one
comment that uh martin coburn made
which i thought was very interesting um
he mentions that in 1969 the
nobel laureate physicist eugene wigner
gave a set of
lectures at yale and the last one was on
the future of quantum mechanics
and that his thesis was that the future
was actually in biology
willis lamb who was another nobel
laureate physicist
took great exception to that idea
claiming that there were no such
applications
so i guess the the future really has
shown us
that there are these incredible
synergies and
convergences in completely unexpected uh
places
so um thank you so much susan for this
wonderful talk and for your vision and
for your leadership in executing many
pieces by demonstration of
how innovation in the academic landscape
ought to look like
and how it could possibly change all our
lives for the better
so thank you so much uh for coming we
were hoping to
um have you come in person but you know
we just didn't want to wait any longer
it sounded we already postponed it from
last year
and but regardless of a talk you're
always welcome
right and um tamar we would be thrilled
to have you on campus
and um and um come in person to new
haven
uh priya tamar peter thank you so much
for inviting me to be part of this
uh even though virtual i can feel the
yell of
and uh uh i'm still part of you guys
but i look forward to coming back on
campus yes and i think uh peter and
tabar
you know we're planning up all kinds of
parties and receptions and so on so
uh you have a rain check for a visit to
new haven
uh thank you very much everyone for
attending and i look forward to seeing
you at the next
frankie event